>> IT'S AN END OF THE ERA AS WE
SIGN OFF THE LAST DON LEMON
TONIGHT.
A LOT HAPPENED BETWEEN 10:00 AND
MIDNIGHT OR LATER.
JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
>> THIS IS THE DON LEMON SHOW.
AND HOW DOES A PLANE SIMPLY
DISAPPEAR.
>> AND IF YOU COULD THINK OF IT,
YOU COULD DO IT.
.
>> UNDISPUTED TRUTH.
>> AND YES, KILLING THE GAME.
>> I'M JUST BEING ME, BE HONEST.
>> THIS IS NOT A WAR ZONE.
.
>> AND UNDER MANDATORY CURFEW.
>> AND EXTRAORDINARY DAY FOR
AMERICA.
MANHUNT.
THIS IS ON A DAY, CHANGED THE
LIVES, RULING SAME-SEX COUPLES,
COULD BE LEGALLY MARRIED IN
EVERYONE OF THE 50 STATES, AND
THIS IS THE DAY, PRESIDENT
OBAMA, CAME TO CHARLESTON AND
TURNED INTO A MOVING, ON RACE.
>> AND I'M THE LEAST RACIST
PERSON THAT YOU HAVE EVER MET.
>> WE'RE LIVE IN LAS VEGAS.
HERE'S OUR BREAKING NEWS.
INVESTIGATORS, PIECING TOGETHER,
CLUES TO THE WORST MASSACRE IN
MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
.
>> TODAY, 17 LIVES ARE OVER.
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US, IS
JUST PLAYING THE ODDS AT THIS
POINT.
ARE YOU REALLY WILLING TO KEEP
PLAYING THE ODDS.
>> THE RACIST, WHITE SUPREMACIST
COWARDS, THIS WEEKEND, EVIDENTLY
FEEL THEY HAVE NO REASON TO
HIDE.
THEY BOLDLY SHOWED THEIR FACES.
.
>> THIS RACE THING, IT'S TAKEN
OVER, YOU KNOW.
AND BECAUSE, ONE, BECAUSE WE
FEEL THE PRESIDENT, IS TRYING TO
DIVIDE US.
>> THEY HAD MY BACK.
>> SIR, IF YOU ARE GOING TO GET
JUSTICE FOR GEORGE FLOYD --
>> TO THE FLOYD FAMILY, BEING
SILENT, YOU'RE NOT INTERVENING
TO ME, YOUR COMPLICIT.
>> THE NATION'S CAPITAL IS UNDE
CURFEW TONIGHT.
LAWMAKERS RECONVENED TO COUNT
ELECTORAL COLLEGE VOTES ON ONE
OF THE DARKEST DAYS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS, THAT'S WHA
YOU ARE.
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
WHO ARE GOADED ON BY THE
PRESIDENT TO ATTACK ON OUR VERY
OWN CAPITOL.
I WANT TO LET THAT SINK IN.
>>> HERE IN LEVIV THERE ARE A
LEAST 2,000 REFUGEES.
>>> THE BEST OF COMMODITY THA
HUMANITY EFFICIENTLY SHOWS UP I
THE WORST MOMENTS OF VANITY.
>> THIS COUNTRY HAS LOST ONE OF
OUR GREATEST TREASURES.
ARETHA FRANKLIN.
[ ♪ MAY BECOME A NEW FULFILL ME.
I MISS YOU ♪  ]
>> THIS IS IMPORTANT TO ME AS
YOU CAN PROBABLY TELL.
>> IF THIS IS CNN BREAKING NEWS.
>> WHAT WAS THAT ALL ABOUT?
>> WHAT IS THIS ONE?
OH MY GOD.
I HATE SURPRISES.
>> I AM ACTUALLY IN A MOBILE
WEATHER VEHICLE NOW.
>> HOW DO YOU KEEP A HEALTHY
LIFESTYLE WHEN YOU EAT COOKIES
ALL THE TIME?
>>> THANKS FOR COMING IN.
[ ♪ AUDIENCE SINGING SWEET
CAROLINE ♪  ]
>> Don: WOO, I CANNOT LEAVE THI
HAPPENED.
OKAY, WHERE WERE WE?
HA, HA, HA, HA.
AND ITS WHERE WERE WE, RIGHT?
THAT WAS BEFORE THE COUNTRY WEN
TO HELL IN A HAND BASKET.
>>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
IT.
THE FINAL DON LEMON TONIGHT.
IT'S BEEN A BITTERSWEET MOMENT
FOR ME, BUT IS NOT GOING TO BE
SAD MOMENT.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE SAID ABOUT
IT, I'M JUST GOING TO MISS
WORKING WITH ALL THE GREAT
PEOPLE REALLY WORK THEIR BUCS
OFF EVERY SINGLE DAY TO PUT THI
SHOW ON THE AIR.
SO TONIGHT, THIS ISN'T ABOUT ME
THIS IS ABOUT YOU GUYS.
IN THE CONTROL ROOM AND THE
STUDIO, THIS IS ABOUT YOU.
TEN HOURS OF LIVE TELEVISION A
WEEK WITH, HONESTLY, NOT ALIVE
RESOURCES.
EVERYONE IS IN BED PEOPLE IS
QUITE A FEAT.
LIKE GIANT APPARATUS WHENEVER,
EVERYONE IS SLEEPING, EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE A 24 HOUR NEWS
ORGANIZATION SO WE ARE UNKNOWN
LOT HERE.
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE PEOPLE,
ALL OF YOU GUYS FOR MAKING ME
LOOK GOOD.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
THE CONTROL ROOM, THE PEOPLE WH
PUT ON THE SHOW, HAVING MET BAC
FOR MISSING DENNIS, PT ME TO
BALLGAMES, BIRTHDAYS, SPELLING
B'S AND DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS.
ALL OF IT WHILE GETTING HOME
BACK TO YOUR FAMILIES AFTER
MIDNIGHT, ONE OF THE KIDS, AND
THE HUSBAND'S, AND THE WIVES AN
THE PETS ARE ALL SLEEPING, ALL
BECAUSE YOU BELIEVED IN ME AND
YOU ARE COMMITTED TO PUTTING US
ON THE AIR THAT BEARS MY NAME.
I AM IMMENSELY GRATEFUL TO ALL
OF YOU.
HE WILL ALWAYS BE MY FAMILY.
WE WERE ALWAYS IN THIS TOGETHER.
WHEN THE CRITICS A TECHNICAL
HERE MY BACK, WHEN THE
CONSERVATIVES ATTACK ME, YOU
HAVE A BACKUP WHEN THE LIBERALS
A TECHNICAL HUMAN BACK, WHEN
RACIST ATTACHED, YOU HAD MY BAC
PEOPLE AND SPEAKING OF, WHEN TH
FORMER PRESIDENT SENT ARMIES OF
BIGOTS AND PEOPLE WHO THREATEN
MY LIFE AFTER ME, YOU HAD MY
BACK AS WELL.
OUR LIVES CHANGE TOGETHER IN
BOTH GOOD AND UNFORTUNATE WAYS.
WE CELEBRATED THE BIRTH OF NEW
DON LEMON TONIGHT FAMILY
MEMBERS, AND SAILING WE SAW THE
DEATHS OF CLOSE FRIENDS AND YOU
LOVED ONES.
I WILL NEVER FORGET ONLY FOR
CARRYING ME THAT I COULD BARELY
STAND.
>>> AFTER WALKED INTO WORK
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO AND I FOUN
OUT MY CITY HAD DIED SUDDENLY,
AND THAT MUCH I COULD NEVER HAV
EARNED A CAR OR A FLIGHT.
I COULDN'T HAVE EVEN FOUND MY
WAY TO THE ELEVATOR TO THE
ENTRANCE OF THIS BUILDING, IF
YOU HADN'T LITERALLY HELD MY
HAND AND WALKED ME OUT OF THE
BUILDING.
SO THANK YOU, JEFF.
AND MARIA, AND LOOKED, AND
LYSSA, AND RACHEL, AND JENNY,
AND ZACH AND MILT AND SUSAN, AN
EVERYONE ON THIS TEAM.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON ON THIS
TEAM.
I DIDN'T MENTION YOUR NAME, IS
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME.
I DON'T WANT TO GO OVER, IT IS
NOT BECAUSE ARE NOT APPRECIATED
FOR EVERY, ALL OF YOU GENTLEMEN
IN THE STUDIO WHO KEPT ME SANE,
WHO MADE ME LAUGH, AND LADIES
THAT MADE ME LAUGH, AND GOT ME
IN TROUBLE MANY TIMES BECAUSE I
WAS REACTING TO WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
I AM ETERNALLY GRATEFUL TO ALL
OF YOU.
I WANT TO THANK YOU WANT THE
LAWYER BLUE -- LOYAL VIEWERS
THAT MAY MASK DURING CURRICULAR
CARDS AND LETTERS OF CONDOLENCE
DURATION, CHRISTMAS CARDS, SO
MANY, MANY, GIFTS AND PRESENTS
OVER THE YEARS, SO THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
EVEN SENDING ME FOOD.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT GOING TO MISS
THE BRAIN FOG FROM THESE HOURS
OF GETTING OFF AT MIDNIGHT, NOR
THE LATE NIGHT MEALS WHICH GAVE
ME THAT AND I GAINED SO MUCH
WEIGHT TOGETHER PEEPING AM I
RIGHT?
>>> SO, TO VIEWERS AT HOME, I
WAS NOT PERFECT BECAUSE NO ONE
IS PERFECT.
THERE ARE IMMENSE PRESSURES THA
COME WITH THIS JOB AND IN
PARTICULAR THIS TIMESLOT AT
10:00 O'CLOCK WHEN PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BED.
SO SOMETIMES ALL I COULD DO, I
AM GOING TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
IS JUST SMILE AND JUST GET TO
THE COMMERCIAL BREAK SOMETIMES.
SOMETIMES IT WAS EXHAUSTING,
BECAUSE SOME OF THE THINGS WE
DISCUSSED HERE ARE SO PERSONAL